When you picture a superhero, who do you see?
Batman?
Superman?
Spiderman?
The Hulk?
Thanks to a growing collection of data, we
know that our cultural icons are not consistent
with what we look like as a country.
This fact extends to virtually every form
of mass media in the States.
Our best data suggests that the American population
is roughly equal in gender, and about 38%
are a minority of some sort.
Which reveals a simple truth about the
latest Marvel superhero film:
People are excited about Black Panther because
the demand for media that centers minorities
is far greater than the available supply.
This becomes obvious when you look at a series
of studies by UCLA’s school of sociology.
Much of what we knew about diversity in Hollywood
was anecdotal.
So we decided to design a report that would
be the gold standard in terms of looking at
the birds eye view of what’s happening and
tracking that over time.
Roughly 1 out of every 10 major films are
directed by minorities.
A similar percentage cast minorities in
their lead roles.
And even fewer of these films are written
by minorities.
This principle applies to nearly every facet
of media, including executives and talent agents.
You can’t underestimate the role of the
gatekeepers.
If you’re not on the roster, you’re going to have a hard time breaking in.
Which of course has created obstacles for
people of color and women, in particular.
Which means that the culture represented on
screen is determined by a sample that doesn’t
accurately represent the population.
If you look at pop culture depictions of Africa,
you don’t ever get to see this place that’s
supposed to be the future.
Wakanda is almost like this rewriting of history
of what life would’ve been like.
It’s this amazing fantasy that you never
get to see on screen.
Black Panther is all about representation.
It centers the story on women and people of
color.
And that representation matters to young people. They're the future target audience.
The minority share of the population was relatively
low in 1970.
But today, nearly 40% of the US population
is in a minority group.
And that percentage is only expected to increase.
The genre doesn’t matter.
Audiences want to see people like themselves
on the screen.
If you have a good story, and the narrative
is compelling, and you have people of color
in it, then diverse audiences are probably
going to go see it.